[Music]
good morning just got back from a
workout early morning I found a little
uh mom and pop gym which I love I always
support mom and pop teams this one's
especially CUNY because around by an
older man he's been training for 35
years I think he's uh uh 70 years old so
if you're ever in Mammoth they're open
early they open at uh 6 a.m but he's
there at 5 30 and it's called The Body
Shop
okay we're thinking to go pee soon okay
because someone doesn't want to take her
to go peek he's scared of the cold I'm
watching your son while you're going
that's true
one definitely made a lot of muscles and
it's CUNY to come back to see Mama make
yummy breakfast not really that looks
yummy it's just oatmeal I love cozy
stuff like this it's so CUNY taika yeah
look at those little butt button there's
guys on top of the roof getting rid of
okay so take a look at the view the view
is insane you guys saw it last night
right look at this
wow Winter Wonderland this does not feel
like America feels like I don't know
Switzerland Austria Germany or something
dude
look at those icicles
and there's a gondola which we'll be
doing today I think that one's for the
actual ski lift
we're going to be doing the scenic one
that's like 15 minutes long that was
gonna be so cool
all right so we ran into a problem not
too big of a problem but it is a problem
originally when I mapped from Mammoth
Lakes to Tahoe it showed up as like two
and a half three hour drive
and um as the main driver for this trip
every morning and every afternoon I like
to confirm the routes because sometimes
I'll notice that like Maps or Google
Maps will update things
and it is imperative for us to get to
the new location by 7 PM because I was
really not all know if I could get
seizures so it's super important for us
to get them in bed by 8 8 30 p.m so
um we have to leave based off of that
time and originally I thought we could
leave at around like 4 pm and then add
an hour buffer and still get there at
around sevenish
um but I confirmed
Maps today and you'll notice that
usually
from this is the this is where the hotel
we're staying at right now
oops How does it go like that let me see
so you'll see that the hotel's right
here
Lake Tahoe are hotels over here there is
a direct path the 395 and that was what
would have been like two and a half
hours
the problem is a bunch of these roads
are closed off due to snow and inclement
weather so it's rerouting us this super
long route
which you can tell is
5 and 25 5 out of 25 minutes it doesn't
say what's going on here like when you
click it like nothing really happens
so for those of you guys who are
planning long trips
um there can always be curveballs so
what you want to do if you're in
California this is a little like
traveler's note you can always go to
Caltrans which stands for California
Transportation or Transit and if you
type in the current Highway you're on
um like 395 and it'll tell you the
conditions so from right here in central
California from Lee Vining to the
junction of Sr 182 in Bridgeport due to
snow motorists are advised to use an
alternate route because it is closed so
that is indeed right here the Vining uh
bridgeport's right there if I zoom in
you see where uh
Lee Vining I see it right here so from
here to here it's closed so no matter
what we can't go that route so
originally the plan was we're gonna do a
really cool gondola ride and then
explore and do some other things I think
in Mammoth Lakes we could only do
one activity which is the gondola right
and then we gotta get on the road which
is cool I mean we just gotta roll up the
punches but it's always good to plan
ahead versus to get there and then get
snowed in where the roads close and then
now you have to turn all the way back
around and then the five and a and a
half hour trip turns into like eight or
nine and that'll be really dangerous
hey monkey can you stand up
you look so cute in your overalls at his
fleece dramas oh my God it looks so cute
turn around
Yay good job
king of the world
okay monkey we're about to go on the
Gondola are you excited
[Music]
you've been there
Circle this one this one's humongous
that's different huh
yeah it goes up and it's 15 minutes long
it's a long one
very cold mama just looks so good
dang it another problem so I guess it
snowed so much that a bunch of the ski
lifts are closed including the Panama
Panama one so they are running it like
they're trying to de-ice all the cables
and stuff but we're not able to go on
there which sucks because I wanted to
get like a really cool view I thought
it'd be super cool especially since I
was in a gondola in Austria and I'd like
to see like how the mountains compare
I don't know why they let me buy the
ticket yesterday but it says we'll be
delayed due to heavy snowfall so this is
where you can check like the status on
all the
key lifts some of them are open but
that's mainly for skiing and like
snowboarding the one that we're looking
at is for the scenic one so
I think we're just gonna pull over and
still try to make a really cool trip out
of it let taika but I think all he
really wants to just jump in the snow
and then
so we'll just go and explore and find
something
so it kind of makes sense why they shut
down a bunch of these ski lifts
because everything is covered in snow
from the ground to a bunch of the signs
you can't even see some of the signs
that are just buried like there's Parts
where the walls were 20 feet high
[Music]
so we're just gonna try to find a spot
that is more kid-friendly not on the
main road
so that we could bring
the Young Money taika and the Young
Money right here he says
and then the Young Money Mia out
all right so we found a little spot off
the side of the road
let the little monkey dude play Hey look
at that guy he's having the time of his
life
but when I was saying this is Winter
Wonderland I was not messing around 360
k
360. no matter where you look
there is a ton
of snow even all the way up to those
mountains up there
what happened you okay
she just lunged forward
I'm just thinking the whole way
see
doing three things
hey good job monkey
good job all right so we're passing
through this small town called bishop
and on the way to Mammoth already passed
through here and one thing caught my eye
in his design Eric shots home of the
original sheepburger bread so anytime
they say home of the mama yeah I know
that it's world famous so I checked Yelp
and there's thousands of reviews from a
small town that's crazy yeah so that's
why I wanted to stop by sick that's why
it's like so Random look but they have
like anytime they have like little
gimmicks and like little Art Deco like
that it makes me feel like they're
really known for something yeah and
they're like the Talk of the Town I
don't know what it is but it seems like
some sort of German bakery or something
is it the shots
I think that's the last name okay
I don't know
okay this place is Bakery Central look
at this cookies
pies cakes oh my goodness pound cake
look at this a guava pound cake that
sounds so good
are we gonna bring a bunch of stuff yeah
yeah huh oh my goodness
wait what diet no I'm just kidding not
but there's a lot this is Bakery I can
see what people come here all the time
now so let's get lunch
um and I know bakeries usually have good
delis so we'll get some sandwiches and
then we'll pick up what we want to take
to your mama I'm super Down AKA us
so I'm assuming all the food
here turkey club oh hot pastrami the
meal kick
ham roast beef veggies all kinds of
Sandwich Shop yeah I'm sure the
sandwiches are gonna be bomb
they also are world famous for their
original sheep herder bread
what is that that or is that a pie
cheaper bread so I have to ask him for
the Sheep Hunter but that's what they're
known for okay
this place does have all kinds of bread
and it looks so good look at this beer
bread
oh my goodness look it's just straight
up look mama
just like sliced bread everything just
looks so good
yeah it's just so like fluffy
pumpernickel
look at all this look at all this bread
Russian pecan Lo French bread look at
this wow
I like how it's all irregular shape too
makes me feel like it's like super fresh
I love how fresh all the ingredients
look look how green that is super green
that is all the dressy cheesy
Sprouts pickles okay great
all right so we couldn't make up our
mind and we wanted to share so we got a
ham sandwich the pastrami one cut in
half and we did a 50 50 split oh that
ham one looks legit
how is it is it a really good hand
sandwich
look at this got a pickle I love old
school pickles like this look at that
pastrami oh look at that mustard that's
that deli mustard
okay I gotta take a bite
is it upside down
okay it does matter it does
not mustard oh Jesus Christ you're just
pulling out of your mouth holy crap
thank you
it's really cool that the pastrami
sandwich also comes with some authentic
sauerkraut
and it tastes really good I've been
eating it
in every bite of pastrami and you get
like a nice little German kimchi up in
there
acidic crunchy refreshing
reset your mouth did you like the
sauerkraut
I don't know if it was lipstick but it
doesn't really taste like much good it's
like a like a little pickled cabbage
like little German German kimchi really
yeah I thought that was like uh what's
the point I mean it just adds texture
yeah I can't really taste it doesn't
taste sour tea
so I think this overpowers that yeah
why do you got mustard on your face
mister
crazy bones
all right done with the meal now it's on
to the fun part the shopping
pull away bread
ooh Peach pull away pull away
that pop whoa Strudels
hey mama you know his name's monkey
strudel there's some real strudels here
what like real strudels real German
Strudels
they got Apple strudels Cherry strudels
what's that green
green that sounds like a good idea
you want to get that or the one with the
turtle so you want to get this for Geo's
mom looks really good Holland crunch
coffee cake I think this one's for us to
share too you want Apple yeah or cherry
or raspberry Apple's good I mean they're
all fun delicious yeah also raspberry
could be really tart for people that
don't like to sour stuff
that is me a sour [__] you want to get
a raspberry there no that's okay okay
but this looks so good can't wait to eat
this with some coffee I mean share it
with your mama
so remember that big old five and a half
hour detour instead of our two and a
half hour drive we finally
made it like we're only 20 minutes away
now
so I think we're coming into Lake Tahoe
which is my first time growing up in
California I've never been to Lake Tahoe
and we're coming in through the south
side which from what I heard is the most
beautiful sign I've ever been through
never never odd schools that's our first
we've both never been to Mammoth you
know this dude we've been together for
like 15 years but you always surprised
me random things all the time okay no I
haven't okay look at this but this is
like trees Galore this is beautiful and
I'm glad that it's not as Snowden as
Mammoth because I couldn't even tell if
they had this many trees yeah we don't
know anything it was just covered in
snow like I couldn't even recognize if
that was a CVS or whatever but this is
gorgeous so I mean we're oh I guess
we're kind of into an already 20 minutes
and I like how the freeway is like built
into the mountain
yeah let's [__] up the nature I like
that it's destruct the nature you just
said that yeah I don't like that that's
what you just said you just said I love
that the freeway is crushing all the
trees and they got rid of all the little
animals that called his home and that we
get to plow right through with all of
our gassy missions and all of our
littering that's so cool you know what
you know what though that's one of the
most beautiful things about NorCal
though San Jose Bay Area you name it
they're they're free which just go right
through nature and it goes right through
the trees destructive dude it does I'm
shedding a tear every time like right
now I'm going
okay
I'm [__] around too much take carbon
dioxide emissions
is that what they do so we're literally
giving these trees food how long does
that take oh look it's a bear family oh
CUNY
we're literally giving trees food all
right all right whoa look how dead that
is holy crap
look at that God damn it my voice
damn
Sam's Daddy this is nice
okay can we just take a second here and
just appreciate
all the trees just blocked my view
always damn it I swear it's a beautiful
view just give me a second
give me a second I think we'll get there
we'll get there
hold a moment oh come on okay I didn't
mean to show you dirty snow okay okay
wait okay wait
oh my God
okay well look at all this stuff okay
here we go ready okay wait
here we go
are we oh no no we'll get there because
look we're gonna we're about to go
that's what I want to show you that's
what I'm going to show you well we're
about to go through a tunnel dude whoa
the BART destruction tunnel
look at this oh this view wow it's
incredible oh my God are you kidding me
look you guys look at this wow wow holy
crap that is majestic
oh macaroni literally
[Music]
wow okay I'm gonna pull it down there
because this is too beautiful no we need
to go I know but it's also golden hour
and we're not we're gonna miss it okay
okay okay okay let's do it we're gonna
miss it because we're leaving tomorrow
so we have to we're gonna leave it like
a baby yes we have to leave like a baby
wow where are we going what does it
matter it does not matter I look like oh
dude this is like a perfect look at this
freaking thing right here yeah
I've heard legendary stories of how
beautiful Lake Tahoe is
and with my small Soul Cal mind I can
only think of Big Bear Big Bear Lake
Lake Arrowhead stuff like that
and uh I'm like oh it's probably like
that on steroids but it is and 10 times
more holy [__] look how big this lake is
it looks like the ocean dude look
I mean I may be tripping but to me Lake
Tahoe looks more like Alaska than it
does California that was the tunnel
we're just in
look at that rock formation
look at the snow
oh my God look at the other side
so I just missed the sunset
because I have to work real quick in the
car
but look at that little Jetty out there
that is a beautiful view
so I I was able to come here and witness
the sun let me show you that I I tagged
it I mean I'm not
um IG is on my mind obviously but look
at that
I was able to capture
the sun earlier where it was right here
it was like that
is that incredible
oh this place is beautiful
we gotta come here at least like once a
year
are we moving again
just kidding
we could live on the Nevada side yeah
yeah because you know there's two sides
to it
why do you want to get wet all the time
to Crazy Bones
okay so this is Super Rad too I did not
expect this so in the middle of this
crazy forest and Wilderness there's
straight up Resorts here too there's
Bally's which is a casino and a Harris
so if you guys like you know don't like
uh the elements too much and you want to
be in a straight up Casino
and you have a device and you have all
the amenities
um that you like from a casino you can
have a hard rock right there look at
that
that's freaking crazy look how big that
hotel is this is a straight up
like mini Vegas
which makes sense because we're on the
Nevada side so I'm sure all the casinos
on this side but that is super cool too
because if you were to come up with a
big family like let's say you got like
10 20 people and you can't all fit in a
cabin or you can get 10 20 rooms e z
I'm actually surprised that it didn't
pop up when I was looking on Expedia but
I did click the pet filter because we
had Mia so that's probably why
but yeah look how cute then oh my God
the views must be insane from there
whoa you like the shiny door Mister yes
whoa this is cool whoa
that is really cool
let's go Mr Man 541
yeah
what
did I say
546 so let's go that way then
it has to go this way
how do you like this one Mister
is it Kenny
oh it's too bad that's Cutie Pies
that's CUNY
all right dude we got our own like
little living room action too yeah
that's pretty cutie we can work over
there without waking them up that's
awesome do you like this one because I
know you had complaints about the other
one
you know the other hotel we see in the
first one that one night long Street in
he was like I don't want to go back to
that one that was not as good as this
one which is the one with the West End
I'm like yeah of course the West is
expensive you found a microwave
you see where's the microwave
are you do you approve of this one you
like this one
so one thing that I love about this
hotel so far is this Atrium it's so cool
I love when it looks like inside outside
like this and I believe in the mornings
they have a
are supposed to be a breakfast buffet
but it's under construction
so probably won't happen there
um it might happen somewhere else but
usually in the mornings I saw like the
ad that there's a breakfast buffet and
it happens like right there but it's not
there
um but anyways it is now 7 45 which
means we're only like 15 30 minutes away
from Taco's bedtime so we're just gonna
order in get some room service get
settled in so we can get this guy ready
for bed and she has been the best travel
partner so far because she plays with
them he plays with her and she gets at
the program
and she's so good in the car never gets
anxious she just knocks out
that girl dude
true that's true
yeah that's true
like look
[Laughter]
having a pretty good Stroke of Luck
every single time I order steak has been
coming out good so this one they had two
choices New York or sirloin I opted for
the New York because it was bigger it
was 12 ounces and look at this
look at the grill marks
that looks pretty good some seasonal
veggies garlic mash
and mama got the shrimp linguine
oh yeah you played tug of war CUNY guy
you love garlic bread huh
you know that's garlic bread
I think the world loves garlic bread
here
good job
you like that yeah I have to be quick
yeah you got a ninja into his mouth
that's how we gotta do it parents team
pants
oh damn clutch
how's yours
by night after wow
and then after we put that I could have
been we still gotta get some work done
because as you guys know when you own a
business
it's 24 7.
she looks so comfy
she just hangs out with us what
you'll record a video
and then you'll be like yo so what what
and you cut it and then right now you're
like
what I wanted to say you didn't cut it
that was so gross
you married me God I know
that I do good night Mama